[Music]
looking to get high on a new water sport
well you literally can riding a flying
water bike it attaches with a long hose
to the back of a jet ski elevating you
up to almost 40 feet above the water
where you can perform aerial flips and
spins the jet skis water thrust feeds
three jet nozzles on the flying water
button one propels the bike upward the
other to feed jet control nozzles that
maneuver the bike the bikes frame is
made out of aluminum parts because it
has to be lightweight as well as
relatively corrosion resistant
especially if it's going to be used in
salt water this curved tube will become
the lifting jet to build its jet control
nozzle a worker places a housing on an
alignment fixture then hammers an end
cap into position
holding the housing steady with a clamp
the worker welds on the end cap this
housing will cover the bushing at the
heart of the jet control nozzle he
inserts an elbow into the opening in the
end cap and welds the parts together
after welding a jet nozzle cone to the
other end of the elbow he welds a
handlebar to the housing these five
welded parts make up the body of the
first jet control nozzle to prep for
painting the manufacturers rough up all
the aluminum parts by tumbling them with
abrasive stones this component splits
the portion of the water thrust that
bypasses the lifting jet sending it in
opposite directions to the jet control
nozzles the lifting jet tube now has a
nozzle cone welded to one end a coupling
for attaching the fire hose to the other
and an oval hole in the curve which
aligns with the angled end of a straight
tube in the middle called the backbone
[Music]
after positioning parallel support bars
between the lifting jet and the splitter
the welder fuses all the parts together
then he flips the assembly jig and welds
on the seat support
[Music]
the seat support attaches where the
lifting jet and backbone meet after
masking the ends of the splitter a
worker sprays the completed frame jet
control nozzles and other aluminum parts
with powder coat this helps protect
against corrosion the parts go into an
oven for up to a half hour to bake the
powder coat to a shiny finish then
workers install an aluminum cam lock to
securely fasten the fire hose to the
coupling another worker attaches the
remaining components to the frame first
he screws in the pair of foot plates on
which the rider stands then he bolts the
bottom half of each plate to the
parallel support bars and the top half -
just ahead of the cam lock
[Music]
he mounts a padded knee rest to the
support bars it can be easily
repositioned to accommodate the riders
height on each unpainted end of the
splitter he installs an internal support
ring then a precision fit nylon bushing
and an external support ring which he
screws to the splitter the worker slides
the jet control nozzle housing over the
bushing and screws it to the internal
support ring the to control nozzles
maneuver the water bike to ascend you
pull back gradually on both of them
simultaneously to descend you push
forward on both to spin you move one
forward and one back and to do a back
flip you yank both control nozzles all
the way back he assembles the water
bikes body it's made of molded
polyethylene with a waterproof urethane
pad to cushion the front of the rider's
body the seat is made of the same padded
material both pad and seat attached with
plastic clips the hollow body is
completely watertight which is why the
bike floats
the final step is to make the body to
the frame the completed water bicycle
weighs 30 pounds once connected to a jet
ski with the fire hose this water bike
flies at a speed of up to 20 miles per
hour by maneuvering the jet nozzles it
does backflips multiple spins and even
dives 20 feet underwater
[Music]